i think the one job on earth sort of
somewhat related to this not dealing
with like getting rid of bugs and stuff
but yeah you know people who clean
houses actually people have died yeah
that's like the one job i don't think i
could do
oh it depends how horribly they die yeah
well because normally you know when you
get older you struggle to take care of
yourself so the house gets like really
like you know [ __ ] mm-hmm
and uh i saw one on about japan it's so
depressing it was just like no it
happens very often yeah yeah yeah and
they go in and they're just like well
we're just gonna take all these guys
possessions and uh trash them and stuff
it's like oh oh that would break my
heart dude just go into someone's house
trying to figure out like what their
like life was like and stuff i couldn't
do it oh i mean i guess i mean like oh
yeah
cause bringing the trash
i thought you meant people who had like
been brutally murdered yeah
i was like yeah that's a pretty that's a
pretty good i mean that's pretty one and
part of it but like what if you're like
uh a guy who like couldn't take care of
yourself you're like 70 and uh you know
maybe you couldn't make it to the toilet
and stuff
i don't know i i feel like i feel like
room smells like [ __ ] yourself oh yeah i
mean it happens like it happens yeah of
course i mean i i think that'd be like a
fine job i mean
god say i'll do it
i mean it's not a pleasant job but i
feel like it would not freak you out
just knowing that like someone was there
like and living there like like a week
ago that would freak me out i think
you'd get pretty numb to it after a
while yeah i mean
i feel like cleaning out you know all of
their stuff you just they'd be like oh
this is this is someone's legacy you
know this is someone's entire life
i don't know just trying to figure out
what what happened like what was their
life like
i think that's super interesting yeah
yeah you get you get like a peek into
someone's not not saying like this is
like a glorious job or something but
like i think you know if someone died
peacefully of like old age or something
and you're cleaning the house i think
that would be like a a really
interesting way to get like really like
what they're like
you know i think unfortunately in the
modern era we have this peaceful
ignorance that we think that uh a lot of
deaths are this like pleasant he passed
away with his friends and family
especially like japan and stuff it's
like no like tanaka-san died age 19 in
his apartment and his family hadn't seen
him in five years and he doesn't have
any friends right and he's just
skeletons and it's yeah it's like it's
[ __ ] happens because the video was
like following this guy that i watched
and he was cleaning it out and it was
just like he was like yep it looks like
he tried to make some food right before
he passed but he wasn't able to oh
you mentioned heartbreaking
curry dude like we all deserve that we
all deserve just a nice before the curry
wait so how would they die then
well you know if you're getting really
old and you're not you know and you're
not able to make it to the toilet and
stuff and you can better get out of bed
and no one's there to help you you know
it can be really [ __ ] oh yeah yeah you
know one day your heart could just be
like i don't think so and then just stop
you know yeah i mean i think there are
worse ways to pass away than that i mean
it's it's they they died in their home
and you know i i think that's that would
be something where a lot of people wish
to pass away i think i think a worse job
is like the people who have to clean up
after like train accidents yeah that
would be traumatic yeah that would like
suck us like to me if i knew a guy died
peacefully i'm you know peacefully of
old age in their own house i'm like you
know what death is never a nice thing
but if there was a way that i would want
to go it'd be like that you know just
just nice and nice and peaceful in my
own in the comfort zone you know just
like very quietly you know just like
reflecting on that person's like me well
you know it's like oh cool this guy
jumped in front of a train i have to
pick up his [ __ ] pieces of his skull
you know i was like i don't i would much
rather do the house job than the other
one yeah i know i i remember i stayed
like uh i remember i stayed like at an
airbnb once
and uh the guy running this airbnb was
like this old japanese guy he was a
student he was like in his 70s or
something and it was like showing us you
know giving us a tour around the house
and
it's a bit morbid actually but
um just like just like one
block away from their house was like a
graveyard right and then and he uh and
we had to walk through this graveyard to
get to his house right and he uh
he pauses uh he pauses at uh at one of
the graves and he talks about oh this is
uh you know my dad's here my uh my gran
my grandad is here um and i'm gonna be
right there
and me and sydney go
oh he's prepared he's prepared cool uh
that's that's that's how did you react
to that
how did you how did you write to you i
got an old guy and being like yeah i'm
going to be there in a few years i'm
like why why not
okay oh out of nowhere but i mean he you
know like i i can't even like begin to
empathize what my thoughts would be like
at that age you know at what point do
you just accept your own mortality and
you just kind of come come come come to
terms with it and come yeah come to
peace with that i think it's kind of bad
ass though to be like you know just kind
of
facing reality and being like you know
what i'm going to be there soon i'm just
going to enjoy life you know while i
still have it kind of thing you know
yeah
he's pre-ordered
he pre-ordered his grace
he had like the space like and
everything i was just like oh it's like
to me as a young guy jimmy is like a guy
in his 30s that's like dude that's
that's a bit morbid to me but i mean i
don't know
at that age i don't know how i'd feel oh
people in japan like everything planned
out
they like everything that's true like i
want to know when i'm dying sorry yeah i
can figure out how many crochets i need
to do okay at which age would you ever
consider
getting life insurance right because
okay because when you get like kids
you're supposed to yeah usually or like
writing a will
right
it's it's it's something you never
really think about but don't they say
that you should write a will like in
your twitter yeah i've won yeah i've
been i've been meaning to yeah i feel
like we're at that age group where we
should have a will already okay okay
here's the thing i think it's when you
have something
you know if you you know we we're quite
successful we've done well yeah and so
if you have some
savings that could be of great help to
your family members or something [ __ ]
the government don't give it to them
yeah make sure you're you know in your
family who gets it yeah yeah so i think
if you have anything
worth giving to your family that is
significant you can you should do well
at any age you know god forbid something
happens but yeah yeah god god forbid
right and to my sister i give my entire
body pillow collection
nothing else do not touch the bank money
who like who am i giving my youtube
channel
i'm literally giving away clout
who wants the clout on my youtube
channel i have already decided that i
want my the reading of my will to be a
comical endeavor so i'm going to add the
most stupid items to my will and be
extremely specific with instructions
just just to get a good laugh from the
grave
yeah i don't know because like i don't
have any brothers or sisters and i would
hope
that i pass away after my parents so and
i don't have any kids right now so at
this point i'm just like when when when
is that if that like awkward
conversation or that awkward realization
to be like i should write a will or i
should look into life insurance because
i don't know like i don't know about
your parents but uh like i remember like
a few years ago my parents told me that
they had started writing their wills and
i'm just like mom dad i don't want to
think about that right now you know
just don't tell me i don't want to like
i i acknowledge it but yeah at the same
time just i don't want to hear about it
i mean my dad just used to meme his will
all the time like growing up being like
if i ever did like a good deed my dad
would be like i'm adding that to the
will
you get an extra item on my will
yes
what the [ __ ]
it's like a [ __ ] competition is like
all right who wants to who wants the
house and the wheel who's it going to be
yeah because like i've told the story of
how like i gave uh my dad like my dad
wanted like a car
yeah right and he's like son the entire
record collection that i have was to
your sister but now it's under your name
now
it feels like yes i'd like to think your
dad doesn't even have a will and he's
just making yeah
he's using the same [ __ ] as he goes
along
probably but yeah i i remember i read
somewhere i think it was on like a
japanese program that they recommend
that you should just write a will like
as soon as you're just like
have awareness
pretty cheap i think any document and
then you get it witnessed i think yeah
yeah
i don't think it's that complicated is i
think it's just like going out of your
way to be like hey i'm going to write
about
the moment after i have passed away and
who gets my belongings and you know
before you think to yourself you're like
i don't have any belongings worth giving
away to begin with why would i write a
will
well my jojo collection needs to go
somewhere who would you give that to who
would you give that to would you trust
one of your family right i would trust
the boys
i'd like to think you'd keep on them
treat
[Laughter]
name won't be like worthless at that
point maybe worth something i don't know
how do you go about like like what is
the structure of writing a will though
that's what i've always wanted to know
like do you write it like a novel or
like a letter like i think you can be
can you write out like a poem
be as playful as you want with it you
ever thought about doing a video will a
video yeah what's up guys welcome to my
will so i'm dead
is this that like the new youtuber
[ __ ]
trend we've had apology videos now we
just have
make sure to subscribe just kidding
you're not gonna get another video after
this you've heard of uh i made this
video five years ago and uploaded it
yeah yeah get ready for i made this
video when i was alive and that's the
way i died
i think that would be [ __ ] cool yeah
i think that would be cool
so if you're watching this video i'm
dead yeah so the payoff might not work
if like youtube like doesn't exist in
like 60 years or it's probably gonna be
like age-restricted and [ __ ] banned
off youtube
imagine that imagine that someone
someone like dies of like a terminal
cancer you can you can play a video of a
dead person on youtube
well i mean it's not you know it's not
you showing the [ __ ] footage of you
dying i mean the the the it's like it's
like me now age 20 i record something
i'm like
not not me like bye guys boom it's like
that
i mean i i mean like the only like
closest thing i could think of was like
the
um the unfortunate thing of what
happened with etika um and that you know
that that got removed my youtube so i
don't know we've never had it before so
i guess we've never had like a president
before of like what what happened
there's these youtubers who have died
and the video's still up i think that
was especially like have has there been
a youtuber who has recorded
their like a goodbye video oh right
before they die no no like like a
goodbye video that would be uploaded
post-mortem you know that does that make
sense without okay can i ask you a
morbid question are you asking that
without the intention of then doing
something very sinister yeah without
these like like
like let's say let's say they have like
a terminal illness or something and oh
yes there is there has been there it is
there was a very
it's a it's a powerful watch um i don't
think i could like i don't
a
think
was vlogging uh his um cancer journey i
forgot the name i wish i knew the name
um off by heart but
it was it's it's it's hard to watch
because yeah you know he's doing well at
some points and then it's unfortunately
it takes a turn for the worst yeah and
the last few videos he uploads are very
painful he's in like the hospice
and um oh god and uh
you know it's really you know i i think
that it's very rare that we had uh
footage of watching that but
yeah he's uh he was uploading a video
and um
yeah he unfortunately passes away but
all the videos are there and his whole
journey's there and uh it's very
inspiring but how cool is it that you
know at least you know all of that is
now documented right forever and that's
just like out there for people to watch
and be inspired by like that's i can
imagine that i think there's a lot of
comfort with it um
i mean yeah it's it's it's it's hard to
watch because it's just i don't think i
could